How do we even get started?
One of the common tricks for a school or exam or test questions
is to work from the bottom, up
and see if there's extra information you can glean.
(x + something) has to be equal to (z)--ah, not super handy yet.
Something is exactly equal to "hello".
Well, wait--right up here we assigned: y = "hello".
So as long as I don't overwrite (y) with 2, this should totally work:
y = "hello" because we just did the assignment
a few lines up.
All right. Now let's take a look at the rest of these.
I need to add something to (x)--to get (z)
that suggests that (x) is smaller than (z)
because we don't have any negative numbers to play with in this example.
So I'm going to have to add something like 1 or 2 or whatnot to (x) to get (z).
Well, if I really think that (x) is less than (z),
then this line is probably True.
But in order for this to print out True and not give some sort of error,
I'm going to have to assign to the value (x) and the value (z) before I get here.
So one of these will have to be (x) and one of them will have to be (z).
Since I want (x) to be smaller,
let's try this out: (x) is 1; (z) is 2.
All right. So then 1 is Less Than 2--that's going to be True.
y = "hello"--that's going to be True.
And now we have: print x + (something) is equal to z.
Well, (x) is 1 and (z) is 2, so we'd really like to just write "1" in here--
but remember the rules of this puzzle--
we can only write x, y, or z so we'll write another (x).
Since (x) is 1, (1 + 1) equals 2.